hello and welcome it's July 27 2023 and
we're here in actin guest stream number
50.1 with Valeria becatini and Anna C
Unica this is going to be a very
interesting and cool presentation and
discussion on selfless Minds unlimited
bodies homeostatic bodily
self-regulation and meditative
experiences there will be a presentation
followed by a discussion so thank you
both for joining and to you Valeria for
the presentation
thank you Diana very much I'm very happy
to be here with Anna presenting a path
of our
[Music]
um
wider project is a paper about what
happened in Southwest state from a homo
suffering body self-regulation
perspective
so it's as I said it's part of a wider
project that consists in both
theoretical and experimental
um
components and
So today we're gonna look at
meditation
so for people that are not really
familiar with that organization is
attracted engaged attention to
self-regulate physiological and
cognitive activity
and what we're interested here is that
people that meditate with a certain
experience so for example meditating in
the past few years with regularly like
some hours per week they can
consistently report losing oneself uh
one sense of the self or having selfless
experiences
but only not only that they also report
to have uh bodily uh alterations
so alterations in the procession of the
body that has been called expansion
Oceanic boundlessness dissolution of
body boundaries and since you are
particularly interested in this kind of
phenomenal experience we have proposed
to frame them as unlimited body just uh
for clarity
so our question here is what exactly and
the question there was we'll follow the
whole uh presentation in the background
is what exactly exactly is lost when I
experience many faces report losing
their self and the body
so let's first looks uh very briefly uh
what what
um the self is or the sounds of selfies
so this content is so complex and so
wide that as we debated since the
beginning of philosophy
um and of course it's so it might be so
intrusive that it's also very hard to
Define but one very old uh old and used
definition is
um
the unitary or unique individual I the
first person perspective that laughing
was called the subjectum so something
that lay under or uh stream of
experience thoughts and whatever else
happens to us
that's the subject
um however more recently in cognitive
signs we are appealing to a more common
definition of sense of self a bit more
exhaustive that is um defined as a
multi-dimensional construct and here uh
we will come back on this on this
concept later and we'll unpack it a bit
more
so the aim of this presentation will be
to first of all lay down the fact that
in self-experiences the biological
organism so to speak the the human body
remains successful that self-regulated
and this uh might be very intuitive but
it needs them to see that
during selfless uh experiences what we
propose is that they may be uh tacitally
a compiler yeah implicitly underlined by
enhanced connectedness with this
successful self-regulation that we
proposed to Lincoln with a perceptually
attenuated body or what has been already
called transparent body
uh and this uh allows it to
propose it's of course in a working
process and we're very open to uh
feedback at any stage of this
presentation that the term selfless
States may be misleading because what is
lost is an ordinary way to mentally
models the self relation to the body and
the world
so I wrote my is composed as uh as
follows
first I will um
passing through uh debates and
definitions of losing oneself and body
so that means they'll go through
alterations in these um three-dimension
uh during that deep massive state
and then I will introduce King concept
of predictive process interactive info
framework
that are
useful in our explanation
so that then I can uh
um unpack the role of the biological
self-organization and homostatic
self-regulation in constituting our
sense of self
and then Pastor or uh claim that the so
much process is like some other sensory
attenuation and transparent self
modeling our key mechanism underlying
the phenomenology of the Methodist
States
our conclusion and present uh ongoing
related projects
so let's back come back to the sensor
itself
so uh in the
um
in when one has to uh investigate the
sense of self of course it as I said
it's a wide concept there so many
definitions and
um characterization of the sensor cell
has come up uh in philosophy and
cognitive science so we have uh terms
like minimal self self experience
self-hood sense of ownership and all of
this and
for author I think we have just to stick
to a common definition
that comes for example from from a
similar paper from Gallagher to thousand
that defines it as a multi-dimensional
construct composed by minimal or
embodied components and narrative or
reflective components so to unpack a
little bit these two concepts the
minimal embodied experience of the sense
of self is the basic
um implicit functioning of the um by the
YouTube of the ongoing moment so the
stream of experience that happens uh to
me right now uh can be defined as my
minimal sense of self so I don't really
need to have an explicit knowledge about
myself
to have this kind of Dimension uh and
these uh can be further unpacked through
the accounts of our pre-reflective
self-consciousness that comes uh from a
phonological tradition tracing back from
uh about to
uh uh argue that uh parts of our
self-conscious does not does not really
need any reflection to to happen there
or in place an explicit thought it
happens
um in a way tambrian uh is
conservatively before uh reflection and
then on top of this we build our
narrative or our Reflections about
ourselves and this is more linked to uh
self-identification processes or
self-monitoring self-recognition and
introspection introspection it's it's um
the ability of
introspect so perceive yourself or
reflect about yourself in an explicit
way
so you do need to have a biography or an
explicit memory about yourself in order
to tackle this this aspect of this
answer so
so indeed massive States uh the there is
alterations in sense of cell and it's up
to debate what which
um Dimension are affected by that and
it's far from Clear what
um actually
happens to these kind of Imagine a more
and many more other dimensional sense
itself uh and we are here uh to unpack a
little bit this
we propose these quotations from Fashion
2008 uh where
um it suggested that one in doing deep
messy stage one experiences oneself and
this very moment of Consciousness this
is a quotation that may reveal some uh
position about this
um the debate what happened to the sense
of self so in this case it's disarged
that meditation reveal a very moment of
conscience so there is something uh that
is true consciences
or uh something that is the real
Consciousness and this actually has
breaks to the concept of pure
Consciousness so something that it stays
there and uh
um it's
um purified by everything by almost to
the body and there is so many uh
definition of this pure Consciousness we
brought some example like uh ownerless
Consciousness the conscious that doesn't
have an owner that doesn't have a self
so it doesn't have as proper sense of
self that walked or that owns this
constant uh nothing it has worked on the
minimal phenomenal experience defining
it a special a temporal dimensional
consciousness
and this is uh very supportive because
it's consistent with the Buddhist
philosophy philosophical standard of no
self so for the uh most tradition of
Buddhism the
um there is no self the self in is an
illusion and it comes uh to our
psychology when we enter in contact with
the world and with the sensations of the
world and certain uh patterns of
behavior the analysis the tension we
have a self
so as it's that many patient it
allows us to access this pure
Consciousness for for supporting to this
thesis and reveals one to choose an
essential nature or subjective and we
bring this into debate
uh
there are also uh people that argue
against this and it's called Uh it has
been called by Imagine their
special issues the ubiquity thesis
so the ability thesis claim that
essential cells is ubiquitous to all
states of Consciousness and sometimes it
appeals to the immunity to error through
misidentification
argument of self-ass position reports
which is simpler than this long name
um and it's basically
the fact that I can say that I had a
wonderful experience or I can and this
wonderful experience may be true or
false this is uh this on this weekend uh
I can do mistakes I can make mistakes
but I cannot not say that I didn't uh
had this wonderful experience because
the moment in which I report
uh I have a perspective on this so I
cannot really be mistaken on the fat end
reporting this maybe I was dreaming
maybe it wasn't a wonderful experience
but it's me there remember party so the
moment I'm reporting this it means that
I have to be there
and this is uh for uh applies also to uh
when I ascribe myself a selfless State I
had a self-estate this this is very
controversial
other problems on top of that are
cross-cultural problems also addressed
in the leadership so this experience
selfless state may be influenced by uh
certain vows or certain beliefs that
meditators are endorsed
uh especially in during especially
expert meditators
and the other uh thing is uh these uh
all
um
um cross-cultural analysis and debate
about yourself maybe also uh actually
due to our verbal
misunderstanding so that the western
western employee may have problems about
the self that actually the Asian
probably philosophy is not really
addressing so there might be some
incommensurability of of problems there
but as also we said in the in the paper
uh it's not there we want to address the
Buddhist philosophical problems but
rather we want to bring inside from from
these two to our to our problems
so the
um given this debate uh we want to
propose a shift in the focus so we don't
want to start by looking at
Consciousness and trying to solve things
about the self but we want to start by
the by focusing on the body so we
proposed a shift in focus in the bodily
experience examining this uh the
imaginative state
so
let's start by the subjective experience
of the body or the study or this ability
to experience of the body which is
phenomenology
uh in the tradition our body has a
unique stages
so the anatomical structure of the body
uh has been called by user cup so the
living body the body that I can observe
and others can be observous is the
object among the other object they would
say
but it's not only that because
uh it's an object that I can live from
inside so it has been called the live
the live body or the body as I leave it
from inside as I said
so what happens uh to these kind of
Dimension again we can unpack this and
see how the meditative States affect
them
so from the point of view of the life
believed body uh we already know and I
will unpack a little bit more so we have
already said that uh we have called
unlimited body experiences uh the three
parts that spoke about this
um fading of the body boundaries so the
body bungee has been defined as a
cognitive emotional perception of uh
one's body surface that just finishing
we can also debate about this but well
it's important for us that our sense of
body boundaries is flexible and dynamic
it's not fixed because we are in the
realm of the body as Fells from inside
there is an interesting study that
exemplifies this concept in relation to
meditation in its uh by John brand in
2016 though it has worked uh late
further on on this um as well but I find
it interesting to look at this image
because
this is part of a self-report management
that they use on a sample of people that
has been trained in meditation in
particular with the body scanning so
that people had to systematically scan
sensation rise in the body
and the result is that in the less than
four months of practice so no actually
not the expert they already started to
report an increased tendency to go
towards the
almost imperceptible
perception of the body so they conclude
that um meditation can be actually
studied in this sense where it affects
our sense of body boundaries and uh they
say they saw significant uh results also
in relation to increased mood happiness
and
decreased anxiety and regulation but
this is uh yes another story that we'll
come back later
so I find interesting also this
quotation by I think uh here in this
paper is talking about why in good
dissolution may be better understood as
ego expansion and then
um and then either the solution becomes
an a later uh
interpretation
um and so I will read it it's it's not
the feeling of self that dissolves with
the boundary between a feeling of self
and the feeling of anything else in
consciousness
so here again I think he's talking about
consciousness but
from our perspective this conversation
is pretty uh informing because it goes
in our interaction as well because
he says it's not that you're losing
really yourself is this this experience
is uh dependent on how you actually
perceive your boundary with uh you and
what you don't consider you so
self or fading of the self other
distinction ability
so
here it comes uh processing acting from
framework because we want to
um
basically breach these phenomenal
subjects you experience to having this
phenomena and underlying mechanics
explanation
uh indeed the processing activities I
have recently used for this purpose also
meditation research and uh
Psychopathology research and so on so in
this presentation I will use them in an
interchangeable way but following
certain uh Trends but it's not it
doesn't have to be it's also under
debate
um and I will also give if I uh purely I
don't know how to say
um theoretical
perspective on that I will not go too
much technical
um so briefly uh this framework
considers uh
brains as predictive machine or as a
freezing likes to say as a considered
brain is a fantastic organ uh which is
because not it's not only uh able to do
amazing things but also because it
really generates fantasies about the
world and this is because the in order
to act interact with your with Excel and
the world around the brain constantly uh
anticipate
um
the few anticipate the state current
state of affairs
in order to make sense of the sensorium
or the stream of experiences that
happens
um so on uh so it possessed or embody or
uh utilizes it depends on the commitment
uh a generative model which is a model
that keep tracks or regularity of the
world and forms prediction out of it in
a hierarchical way so highly
reproduction uh goes down to match uh
sensory data
um and sensory data goes up to uh
um map to affect the predictions to
update the model
however every prediction comes with a
degree of error which sometimes is
called prediction errors so
this predictionaries the discrepancy
between prediction and
um sensory input so that a new model is
generated and uh they say the
um first imperative or the only
imperative of the system is actually
minimizing the prediction errors so that
the model can most efficiently uh cope
when interacting uh and act in the world
however it's not um
the only imperative because the as I
will introduce in this Slide the
the system uh has also to
estimate the confidence or likelihood or
Precision of prediction in order to
evaluate the prediction errors uh that
are coming from
the discrepancy
so that the generative model has to
compute enough a fine way uh how how
much Precision to assign the to the
prediction or prediction errors
and I choose this image because it
renders well
um
how the distribution are
um set depending on the prestigious
sedation so if you have a precise
medication error
then the posterior distribution will be
closer to the prediction error well the
imprecise prediction have lethal effect
on the prior so that the procedure the
the pursuit distribution will be closer
to the prior and this is very important
because if the
um that Precision estimate are not
weighted correctly then the system
generates false inference that will not
able to the system to interact
efficiently and update model efficiently
so so far we have uh mostly talked about
uh prediction error minimization uh by
updating uh the model however the system
can also uh active samples or active
modifying the prediction error of the
world
um in order to fit
uh the prediction errors to the world
and this comes into play active
inference
um that builds upon the free energy
principle where uh that um is based on
the idea that living organism
maintaining themselves with an optimal
State set of states
that comes from the second low dynamics
of shortening Schrodinger
um
so given that
it comes into play uh how attention is
uh
analyzer examine it under this framework
so given that uh the organism has to
maintain uh Within These optimal
assessor states by maintaining an
optimal balance between uh computation
uh and precision optimization SO waiting
between uh prediction and
um prediction errors attention comes
into place as a modulation of these
Precision of sensory data working as a
Searchlight so in other words it
optimize the signal to noise ratio it's
the one of the way that we have to uh
put in place in place these local
optimization of precision estimate
and this is very important uh why we
bring into attention because meditation
has a systematic energy
reservative use of attention resources
um
and we will come back into that
further on in this presentation
uh and given that we are interested in
okay we have seen the live body what
happens to the funeral experience now
we're interested in what happens to the
corporate what happens to the living
body that can be observed by the the
organism that during medicine States
in these bring we brings into play in
other two uh important concept uh in
active immigrants which is a way to uh
self-regulate
um
the underlying all and what experience
Soul subjective experience
so two ways uh
or one way that then is also active so
the first way is homos little homostasis
which is the maintenance of required
optimal Say by survival and reproduction
of self-organizing biological system so
for example I'm cold and I use my
internal resources to keep my
state into this into optimal state so I
start shivering however I can also put
in place uh active modification in the
world so that
um I'm not cold anymore
so for example I take a blank this is
called elasticity so it's active
engagement and modification about the
environment in order to maintain myself
in optimal States for survival
so we can say
uh of course human bodies are
self-organizing biological system and
aiming at keeping these internal States
within a certain uh viable range for
survival
now given that we will come back again
to phenomenology
off touch I will go I'm going to to do
this for the second time
uh to then wrap up everything again
uh so we have talked about film all
video of the body
however uh we haven't uh underlined
important is that the touch and proximal
sense has for our lip body
so
our as Technica and colleagues has
already
um
proposed our proximal sense are Central
for our minimal sense of self
and on this on on top of that we bring
important to play the fact that
different kinds of touch can convey
different experience of this and so
stuff or sense of boundaries so for
example imagine yourself that you are
um in a c
of partial or California and
you touching the whole environment with
your body
you may feel that you have a sense of
immersiveness or that your body
boundaries are
slowly a bit becoming less clear and
this experience it's actually a bit
similar to the experiences of sensory
deprivation States where people are put
in a salty water and they let them flow
for some moments
sensory deprivation states are not
really really all deprived because you
have other activities in the body and
movements that produce signals that you
are actually aware of
however in both these experiences the
body boundaries seems to fade a little
bit
however if you're in the cnu's meeting
and then you touch the rock with your
hand uh you clearly will feel yourself
as separated as uh something different
from what you're actually touching like
sense of separation
things phenomology can be both
[Music]
interactive inference through the
mechanism of some of the sensory
attenuation which comes from the sensory
attenuation
so this process happens when uh the
system depicts your its own action
uh so for example I take a glass
uh and in this moment my Rena has
already created a different copies of
this action and the sensory consequences
of this so whenever I grab the
um these this class the sensory concept
that happens to my uh but they are
slightly
um attenuated
and this is why we cannot tickle
ourselves
because the prediction errors comes at
not surprising
this has a implication for our embodied
experience in the world because we are
feel that we are immediate immediate
content with ourselves in the world and
this is because
our country experience are mediated by
transcript or non-perceived cognitive
processes so that the system leads can
leave behind or this attend self-related
sensory processing
so and these allowed to allocate your
resources to perception and action
involved in the processing of the object
of Interest
so for example when uh limousine as this
example of the Cherry when I have to uh
take a object that Italian for me I'll
be much more interested in the uh
picking the object and I will not really
focus on my arm boring
in picking that
so that the system needs to compute and
maintain a fine balance between external
and internal comp components of some
other sensory attenuation
and this is very important for the sense
of self as well
so it uh we need to understand and
result that we need but in order for us
to have a sense of self we normally have
a sense of what we are when we don't and
what we are not but for the brain it has
to uh or as as uh agents end up with the
brain we compute this distinction so
where the self ends and where do work
begins or do I move my arm or my arm is
moved by something or someone
play the role in this uh distinctions
and involved in building multi-sensory
bodily self-representations
so that the sense of the self and body
is uh subjectively and phenomenally
transferred that's that that means that
when we act in the world and we interact
we normally these attend uh the
way we are in the world because we need
to be in contact Direct contact with the
world if we always attend it to our body
and our our
um ourselves in to in the sense that we
will be hyper reflexive then we will be
actually uh will be impaired
in what we normally do and this is
actually a condition that we will talk
about later
so that
in our students in the sense of selfies
and ongoing inferential process center
in the body so what we propose is
uh what is lost during selfish selfless
experience is an ordinary way to mental
mentally model self in relation to the
body in the world so that if we think
about the self as as I propose here then
I uh the iceberg where the narrative
cells is what we see but the renewal
self is what we actually are composed of
and it's actually larger but we are not
aware of similarly when we have software
experience we may have also these uh
inferential process where we think we'll
have lost ourselves
um however
uh we have gathered some evidence in the
fact that meditation facilitate all
genomic regulation involved in
homostatic processes
that means for example that meditation
increase the synchronization of cardiac
and respiratory system
uh this is connected with reduced levels
of blue blood glucose or blood pressure
and heart rate variability so there is a
um
successful medication helps to
successfully self-regulated the body uh
especially in comparison to stress that
actually does the opposite
um
and on top of that uh meditation help us
to attune us to our physiological
interceptive awareness uh and this
um it does it so they say by enhancing
the processing of extra effective
interceptive stimuli which it doesn't
have to be understanded as a maladaptive
uh increased body awareness but rather a
adaptive body awareness which is very
distinguish distinction that we can come
back later if you
if people are interested or they ask
about
um
these evidence are also in line with
evidence communication that promotes
self-regulation of pain and pain and
pleasing and so
three-day attentional training the
meditation
in allow uh you're actually able to
self-regulate the pain and not not
really like the sensation of the pain
because it actually gets very clear but
the uh automatic behavioral patterns
that comes uh in association with the
with the pain
so there is also also self uh regulation
on emotions and so on
so the body doesn't know literally
disappears actually it stays as a very
centered uh as a first year at the
center as we propose it in the paper and
I proposition through this image at the
center of a cycling
so self-regular
self-regulatory processes allow the
subjective experience to lose oneself
so the percent of the body
remains present in the background and
these for example can it's very here
from these reports from a
person undergoing this kind of
experience that they uh say that there
remains a sense that there is a body
without any experience of a sense of
boundary
so
this is
not very last slide but we come to our
wrap up of our claim
uh attenuating the self unlimiting the
body which is also the title for our
paper so
starting from the fact that all medicine
practices across the three Traditions
require
systematic and parallel fully crafted
body preparation to enter these deep
method self-state self-estate so it
doesn't
happen that all of like all of a sudden
you just have a selfless state
which actually may happen more similarly
with a psychedelic bubble meditation you
need
you need to pass through gradually many
different uh state or many of different
um
level of concentration
that happens when you have around a
predictable
environment and you do so by building
prior expectations so you have to keep
your body in a certain position of
posture as you say this in this image
the person is seated with a very
straight but not very but a straight
back relaxed this is very important
realization when it lags and so on
and then you need at least uh in in the
most part of your practice you need safe
predictable environments with
temperature that are enables you to
maintain your homostatic analysis and
processes
so all these conditions are necessary
for your successful homeostatic
self-regulation
in this sense when this part first part
of the preparation to Andrew then after
the state of concentration the meditator
can let go and leave behind self-related
processes and process the body
transported or it can attenuate them
just attenuate its body the body cannot
can be attenuated
so our claim is that a transfer
essential cells and body May underline
the phenomenal phenomenology of losing
one cells one self and blurring body
boundaries as reported during meditative
States
um
so our conclusion is that we have
proposed a shifting focus on homeostatic
body self-regulation in examining the
majority States
the experience of having ability a
living self-organism biological system
is never lost in this process
rather it stays transported at its very
center
self-attenuated yeah very much present
in a handful life
so that the self model is attenuated to
a big week to become transparent
enhanced processed in the background
now giving this conclusion now I'm gonna
present related project the first one is
still uh on the theoretical side so we
are in the real of active inference
model in meditation research there is a
radio literature about that
um that
um base that have studied different
kinds of meditation techniques like
focused attention open monitoring
non-dual awareness
um they have for example uh showed that
these uh attention techniques profoundly
and alter typical mental experiences
and
for example Focus meditation is the
meditation
um that engage attention on one specific
object experience for example the breath
uh and in active events there we mean
that Precision is uh estimated one
century input which means that it
reduced the impact of the other thoughts
and parallel processes that going on
or often open monitoring meditation is
the uh is the engaging of attention to
one's experience as a whole so the whole
stream of experience with us selecting
anything in particular so that in an
active intertherens it has been
described as assigning equal Precision
to all these experiencing promoting
non-reactive sensing and it is connected
also why meditators
are good in self-regulated regulate pain
so in we will also build our model our
us on self modeling based uh on the
previous literature which is in
preparation
and then going experimental uh we want
to bring into the table uh applications
of what we we're researching and
potential benefits may be for a case or
people or yeah individuals that suffer
from disrupted body awareness uh or
disruptive self-awareness
and there is a
relatively recent condition that has
been
studied that is across the
personalization
so the personalization
um is their destruction of both body and
self-awareness and it's a very
heterogeneous condition there is a lot
of different dimensions uh that occurs
but generally uh it's connected with
feelings of Happiness disconnection
feeling the body isn't the as an object
rather than a transparent medium of
experience uh which is uh switching
release called disembodiment
it is linked with difficulties in
concentration and attention often
comorbid with depression rumination and
anxiety
and recently and colleagues that also
propose a uh characterized by failures
in attenuating so much a sensory signals
so
based on what we have uh previously said
and based on how these
um condition affects uh
a large number of population we want to
test certain hypotheses
so the first one would be the highest
somatocentric attenuation correlate with
more feeling of aliveness and wide
openness in experienced meditators
and rather lowest from other Century
attenuation could relate with feelings
of unrealness Badness in people
experience uh decorationalization
and on the other hand severe homeostatic
disregulation or bodily States during
deep Methodist States may lead to
negative emotional outcomes and other
self-experience this comes from to the
fact that
the personalization and meditator and
meditation has some has uh can both
create stressing negative outcomes and
it's interesting to see how these happen
and what are the commonalities and
differences in that
and also we have now in the realm of
spatial temporal perception which is uh
connected also with mood disorders or
like depression and anxiety uh and also
with the personalization
uh however in the precise station there
is no specific items in the
questionnaire that is usually uh used
for measuring so we're which is a Camry
Cambridge the personalization scale so
we want to test this as well uh and we
want to test it uh
in people reporting selfless and
disembodied experience so both
pathological non-pathological conditions
so path of this hypothesis we are
already going through
this is our team coming from Humboldt
University where I come from the month
but also a university Hall and College
London with anus and Joseph
first study is as I said about time
perspective so we want to analyze uh
um how people with high rates of the
crystallization can relate with
dimension of the time perspective so
there are more future oriented or more
negative oriented our hypothesis that
they're more negative past
oriented so they're stuck in
a very
long present moment that but also the
the their the tendency of ruminating so
always going to pass negative memories
um
this is a title lost in dark times the
effect of the personalization
experiencing on time perspective
and these we are already in the analysis
of the data but
um
it's on ongoing still
study so we we have preliminary data on
this
uh while studies two we're in the
recruitment phases but we are almost
there and encompassed the
uh hydrates or people individual with
high traits of the personalization and
meditators
I want to see through a set of questions
and a behavioral task how they may
differ in the sense of self body and
motion of course they're very wide and
conflict Concepts so there is always
room for for
feedback and
replication and so on uh we want to just
we wanted to we have selected this tasks
the embody task that I've adopted from
newmanma
uh where individuals have participants
has two colors parts of the body
um
in relation to activation that they feel
by reading certain emotional story
so these stories at least are supposed
and validated to at least see certain
emotions in the body and then people
colors parts of the body and then we
will see how people with high traits and
visualization limit heaters will will
different this and we will also compare
with other questions that we have put
this and
uh potential title is emotional body
maps of solid Detachment personalization
and meditation
and with this I thank you all and that's
it now we are open for discussion thank
you
awesome thank you very much Valeria
your music down
thank you Valeria
great of course well
very fascinating presentation perhaps uh
on up first and then our other
colleagues who have joined would be
awesome to hear your
after
be here on this work and and any
reflection or questions you have on it
is it my turn sure did I missed yeah
yeah so um obviously I don't have many
questions because it's like we
brought this together so
um
but um I I think what I'd like just to
add that really a question is
um
I really like to see
um so for instance like in um an ideal
world would be nice to you know uh get
all the
um
the tradition of the meditative
experiences and how they relate to the
body and make a very precise prediction
on what exactly they will kind of like
predict in terms of uh certain
um
uh sensory experiences and how this can
be interpreted through different like
theoretical lenses I think that could be
really really interesting because I
think one of the problems
uh the challenges that we have right now
is that we have so many Concepts so many
approaches and kind of like scattered
all over the map and I think would be
really nice to
um you know a narrow down because as you
said Daniel
um so everybody knows what meditation is
everybody knows at least one person
meditates in in life and everything but
uh it's really unclear what exactly we
are um we are after and why in certain
cases this is kind of like
um beneficial and one in another cases
basically it has a negative consequences
and this is why precisely we are doing
this our project on the personalization
and meditation and I can share with you
informally scoop but data is here so it
kind of like I can share with you so
what we did in this project basically we
took people with typical controls that
don't have the personalization and never
meditate it right so it's kind of like
yeah never did that and then we took
people that meditated but
um and then we looked at whether they
have kind of like high or low traits of
depressurization and then we took people
with deeper sizes that never meditate
right
um so
so I have this like
um inclusion in exclusion criteria and
um yeah it's it's really interesting to
find what our finance is like it's
really difficult to find people that
have experienced meditators and low
depersonalization skills low
depersonalization traits right so most
of them they actually have ID
personalization but then it's
interesting to see how that contrasts
with like the people that have the
personalization and no meditation
experience right
um so that's that's something I would
like to
um Carry On and
um yeah so to reach the community and
um yeah
and that's something we will definitely
carry on with Valerian the next steps
and also with some people that I have
here in the chat uh Julia and Simon so
Simone will going to work with us on
also smarter sense retaliation yeah
through different senses and Julia we
have some um without scooping we have
also some very very interesting results
coming up
um we just finished data collection on
intentional binding and
depersonalization so related to the
sense of agency yeah so yeah so that's
all from here just like for now we're
kind of like in between because well I
represented very well like the theory
part and the studies are literally just
getting hot from the oven now and we
hope that in September it's like we're
going to get the mode there yeah but the
data is in the box so that's very
exciting and yeah we have the results
yeah
thank you Danielle again for uh this
platform it's really nice and as I said
I really hope that after this discussion
we'll have more
um um you know
opportunities to change exchange and um
yeah discuss we also plan to organize
something around a duration of
self-consciousness in across various
conditions and also the personalization
in Elizabeth next year so maybe you can
cross the pond and check for yourself
that we have a nice airport in Lisbon
yeah
cool well good to uh get the appetizer
before the entree so that's very awesome
about just how much Theory and um even
unconventional scientific theory like
World Knowledge traditions
come into play and then what it looks
like to take that experimental step to
make it scientific is is definitely what
I
saw on the talk
um Julia or Simone do you want to give
any reflection or any thoughts or
questions
yes I actually have a can you hear me
yep yeah I actually have uh three
questions I know it down
um I think the first one because it's
just for me personally I'm curious about
that is that those deep meditative
selfless States I think that can also be
reached while doing yoga right
basically the opposite of like sitting
still is like a sort of repetitive
movement actually so I'm wondering do
those movements have to be perfectly
predictable in order to be attenuated
and then reaching the same state or is
that like a different uh different
concept or how do you how do you put
that in the in your in your framework
um
mainly to
uh to talk to topics one is is it
possible to reach deep Methodist States
also uh not sitting in a steel position
and the answer is yes
uh
however there is not so much research on
that so I can talk about anatical
knowledge
but I did not read so much about uh
World communication effects
usually works meditation or yeah of
course you talk about yoga I know but
that's what I uh would say that walking
meditation is used uh as a complementary
practice through the same thing
so I would say
hard to reach deep Melody stage only by
World communication
um
in regarding to yoga also yoga means
Unity so what we think about yoga now we
think about movement but it's always
uh occupied by reduced state of
conscious concentration
through meditation
so you cannot have yoga without
meditation otherwise we'll be stretching
your glasses
but uh second topic
is that can it happen when you have when
you don't have prediction of movement
right no I meant like because in yoga I
mean at least I don't really do yoga
right but I can imagine that what when
people reach those States doing yoga
then they kind of do it almost like in a
in a trance type of way they're always
doing the same movement over and over
and over again so that they don't have
to attend to those movements but it's
just like an automatic process I was
wondering if it if that also can I can I
jump in so
um um actually this is precisely the
opposite what is what what Valeria was
saying is so but I was saying this is
precisely the opposite you want to reach
through yoga just like the opposite of
automatic Yeah so basically when you do
this movements you need to be United
with your self-training it so you really
need to
um yeah uh so yeah I'm doing yoga so
they they the past 10 years and
precisely this is like they're trying to
tell us it's like don't don't do it on
automatic because it's like when you
have your thinking happening there and
your body is doing some stuff there
right you need to be basically be
presents in every single type of moon so
you have like a fully fully a presence
if you do it automatically that's like
that's more like gymnastic or something
yeah so um but it's interesting uh so
your point is really interesting because
then would be really nice to have a
control condition where we have people
doing like movement meditation and yoga
and then um contrast with the phenomenon
of like
um uh some other sense retineration and
uh whether they have what type of light
embodiment and disembodiment adjectivity
experiences they have
yeah
okay but yeah I don't know exactly what
I was trying to get it but I think it
was also more related to because you
said that when meditating you have to
sort of
let yourself
letting go exactly the ideas then
everything has to be perfectly sort of
predictable right that's that's the idea
behind it so then I I'm I'm thinking so
you always within yoga don't you have to
do like the exact same movements in
order for it to be predictable in order
for for you to let go and not over
attend to the environment does that make
sense or
if I thought when when were you both uh
on the Simo we're speaking I think on
one side you see more maybe you're
referring to the implicit procedural map
implicit procedural knowledge that can
uh you can acquire through yoga and you
and I are talking about doing things
without being aware which is also
automatic and left and you both are
right I think in this because on one
hand if you and you would say like if
you do yoga you learn how to to do yoga
right so you learn how to uh
um
move yourself in this in this way so
that when you do a certain position you
know then you have to arrange your body
and for a ranger that you always have to
keep monitoring yourself so there is a
continuous going back to your body
keeping track of your body and continue
to monitor yourself but in this way
because you have learned to do this
these um constant constant going back
and being aware on yourself and these
comes also when you you do your movement
you have learned that you certain
posture are made in a certain way so
that it becomes more or less predictable
actually what you're gonna do right but
it doesn't mean that you you don't have
to be aware and actually there is a
trick uh reload here because you're a
very attentive with what's going on but
at the same time the more your attentive
the more so much a sensory attenuation
may happen and actually it's what we are
trying to argue in our active uh
inference model
the the more a predictable it gets the
more it gets attenuated but doesn't mean
that you're not aware that's that's uh
yeah that's good thank you for this
input because it helps us elaborate this
I think it's super interesting because
it's like when you when when you look at
like people that climb or surf or
whatever any type of sports right in the
beginning in order to learn the skill
you have to put a lot of attention to
the individual movements but then later
on in order to actually be good at it
you have to take the attention away and
then in those moments is when the people
report that they're actually feeling
sort of selfless days in this flow
States right which is when the the
movements are internalized so to speak I
think that's that's super interesting
can I can I just shoot the other two
questions I had they're like sort of
different or should we go to Julia first
maybe it's true yes I don't know
I sorry um yeah sorry for the lighting
and sorry because I'm in the lab so it's
probably not the best position uh thank
you very it was very interesting and I'm
really uh looking forward to um yeah
look at the uh yeah the results you you
have in your study especially yeah I
mean since uh as and I mentioned we had
something interesting with the
international Banking and the
personalization and um yeah kind of
happy about that and what I do so I'm
really sorry because I listened kind of
doing something else unfortunately in
the lab I was busy um while you were
talking but I kind of like the idea of
um
yeah that's the self is attenuated or
not or increasing and kind of goes back
to just Simon the last comment from
Simon about expertise
um
I think in terms of motto uh interaction
there is some literal tribality
expert I was trying to Google that
um that I attended a workshop last year
and I think it was about once you're an
expert
you at the beginning you have this kind
of flexical you you you have a better
understanding Consciousness and then at
the end you kind of learn to let it go
to write the flow of the motion kind of
so it's not that you are and I think
it's probably maybe the same I don't
know whether yeah but attention in
meditation is that you have this maybe
more like not focused
uh it does not stay but more like open
um sorry I forgot the name of the
meditation type of mission you know but
open meditation and monitoring yeah yeah
exactly so you I mean I don't know it's
uh so it would be interesting and I
suggested to see what kind of meditation
what type of meditation maybe change the
sense of the self maybe at the beginning
it's more acute because you really
scrutinize your sensation and and then
after I don't know this is something
that you plan to do right or
should I go or do you want to go on
uh the
the first question was I know ah there
is a body of evidence they actually say
that in expert meditators uh attention
to start decreasing
but there is also because you allocate
less and less attention but I would be
careful with that because with with this
because they say there is an uh decrease
that uh decrease activity in anterior
singlet cortex
so they make inference about it
um as as a meditators as well uh and
having to know other people there are
more experienced than me
they would never say we lose our
attention to that because our experience
is so rich our Sanctuary signals and
related thought process that you cannot
afford to not be attentive however we
can drink into the play different kinds
of attention as you said there is
focused attention or there's an
attention that requires more explicit uh
thought about that some more explicit
kind of uh way to focus on things and
there is more like a bear bear attention
so when you focus on the whole
experience and you let things go with a
non-judgmental attitude and more open
attitude and is actually this attitude
we're very stressed in meditation
techniques that's why they're a bit
under lock and in research I feel
because it's it's a lot about how we use
attention but not the intent attention
but not how we use intention so our
attitude has the attitude that mediters
has to be very open and very
non-judgmental and these reduce the
non-reactive incentive for for example
and reduce the ability to self-regulate
the your experience
your life yeah I have
partially answered
you know I mean I kind of like the idea
that you you linked that with attention
and um it's just I think maybe it will
be interesting to look at different type
of attention because
um
whether you know you have like so maybe
there is a difference between I don't
know different type of meditation May
develop different type of I don't know
if maybe the open
um meditation
he's more prone I don't know because you
mentioned the Instagram cortex into me
it's more associated with a certain type
of attention like more like maybe
um more prone for like a feedback
um or negativity or these kind of you
know error monitoring process so it's
not like your attention you lose your
attention it's just it's more like in
the background and then when there is a
mistake or something it kind of pops up
more quickly I don't know and you may
have more like uh frontal or a sustain
attention I don't know I mean I'm not
especially of attention at all so please
take that little bit of self
um yeah I was wondering if this is
something I don't know obviously I mean
because it's only you're not trying to
do any EG or or narrow physiological
measurement right
yeah but in the in the pipeline yeah
okay but we really want uh with um with
Valeria is
um
and other collaborators is to basically
push against this idea that uh you can
have selfless experiences I know it's
controversial and many people talk about
oh selfless experience below
uh so basically we want to say radically
speaking okay though so that works if
you buy the bullet in your mind what you
do a list and somehow consider that
actually the body kind of like
disappears in the process but if you're
not mind body dualist then you need to
make basically put the body into the
equation and realize that actually what
allows the mind to disappear is the fact
into the pureness of the experiences the
fact that the impure body is kind of
like put in a
stable condition in such a way that
basically can afford to live it in the
background and yeah to have like this
type of like um experience arising but
without that in place uh you it can't
cannot really afford to you know go
through the selfless experiences and
this is why we want to be provocative in
the titles that well actually maybe the
experience of like selfless
um you know selfless experiences
actually comes
necessarily as to sign of the same coin
of this experience of like having a
unlimited body that actually expands to
through the world but the body is there
I mean the the thing the The Entity that
has the experience of no experience is
that a body that kind of like is
um self-regulated in a certain way like
the homeostasis is put at like a set
point and when you're using this
metaphor of like think of um
a cyclone Right Moving Cyclone so you
have the steel eye of the cyclone in the
middle doesn't mean that actually is not
there it's just like it's around
everything and because we are
self-organized in biological systems uh
we kind of like this animal this thing
needs to keep track of this internal
bodily states and their I mean just a
successful system does this all the time
all the time literally from second one
when we basically get from one cell to
you know the substanceism some sort of
like fascinating self-organization that
is happening on the cellular level
already and it like needs to be yeah and
death is basically this is what is
happening it's like a single
disintegration of like this
um you know self-organization and um but
that's clearly that's not what is
happening on meditation right because
you do hopefully you don't die when you
meditate in that sense there is a
disintegration of a certain way to
experience yourself in relation to the
body in the world but clearly there's
something that stays there needs to stay
there for you to have those experiences
so that's a bit of controversial radical
claim that we like to defend and uh yeah
we already had this discussion several
people for instance like whatever and I
we've been to uh Enlighten and this
workshop on um of knowledge and neural
computation we met there with people
like Thomas betsiger and everything and
they always have a different opinion so
kind of like have a lively discussion
about why we think it's like
what does it mean to actually Lose
Yourself and what is the self and what
is the pure experience and why we
basically need whether we're like it or
not the connection with the impure body
to make sure that it can have at a
certain point of pure experience but
then but then again this is something
that just speculation at the theory
level and this is why I have this
brilliant team here that we we can do
some uh studies and actually measure
stuff put the finger on it put the
number yeah and see
what we get
these are these are awesome
points and there's so many ways it could
go I'll read a question from the live
chat so G pagnani wrote
the notion of increased somata sensory
transparency in experienced meditators
associated with increased liveliness of
the experience is intriguing can you say
something about which levels in the
hierarchical structure of the internal
model are more likely to be affected by
the meditative attentional tasks in
terms of precision deployment do you
think the attenuation of somatosensory
prediction error concerns more
intermediate levels in a way increased
meta awareness rather than sheer sensory
attention
I just wanted to ask rather than
ensuring
but rather than sheer sensory attention
yeah you can go on now please yeah so uh
um
yeah so this is something I I'm I'm
trying to develop this idea right now
with
um
um a PhD student of mine
um uh Libby uh Liberty service basically
uh and this is why it's connected with
the question that you ask you'll see is
that um
you know your platform is active
inference right and so people are kind
of like you know um
lately kind of like realize wait a
minute actually we're active and we need
to explain action in the world and
everything is kind of like comes late
right but uh if you look uh going back
to the animal basically
um the action and the movement is there
from the very beginning so this means
that this is why it's so important to
basically relate the um um you know
self-organization self-awareness
self-perception necessarily related with
movement not so movement so on action is
not something that you add on the top of
this right like uh and some people like
intention so you can have an intention
but basically the first movements are
kind of like automatic and need to be
there right and basically our body moves
all the time because we breathe all the
time and our heart beats all the time so
this means that for me this type of like
attenuation it's happening at the
sensory level because that's the basic
one so can you have sensory stuff
without metacognitive stuff yes can you
have the cognitive stuff without sensory
stuff no so it's like what what is basic
that's the first things needs to be um
um uh alternated and then then it has to
be a balance between meta cognitive and
sensory attenuation because uh this is
precisely what I think it is happening
in the personalization here because if
you if you focus too much right so if
you lose the the balance right between
then you you basically
um
yeah it's it's kind of like this type of
you cannot afford to sell forget
yourself yeah and then it's kind of like
the self-standing way and that gets to
get you even more disconnected so to
speak yeah uh so this is why I think
it's important to
um uh contrast different type of like a
meditative experiences and meditative
practices to see which one of them
actually
um has more focus on what you do with
the metacognitive metal Oneness
awareness of awareness and which one are
actually involving more like sensory
movement for instance like let's say
yeah so that's that's something that
needs to be um empirically tested but I
would speculate and then obviously we
can put a test either by doing a
simulation or you know actually
collecting data to see how that
um uh plays into this uh distinction
I think Simon wants to say something but
I'm not the moderator So Daniel you
decide
yeah Valeria first and then um
okay uh
yeah thank you Anna that was very uh I
don't have so much more to say because I
agree with her but uh
I thought when Jani and you were reading
the question I for me the answer was
more or less clear in the sense that
um as I say the somatician continuation
happens are the very low level
predictions so
in a very uh pre-reflective
self-consciousness uh so that the person
was asking uh
if you know at least in the meditation
techniques with the when you put the
attention on for example your bodily
signals there you have a top down
modulation of this uh of precision
racing but the top 10 modulation is on
low level predictions
so you're not putting top down on what
you think about your body is you're
actually doing the opposite you're
trying to forget about your uh previous
expectations about the body because
you're trying to have this
non-judgmental awareness about what's
going on in your experience
and then uh with this
um let's say uh less uh biased uh way to
attend your body you start piercing and
perceiving uh
um
bodily uh Sensations in your body or
yourself or other kind of experiences so
I would say
this increasing Precision on
somatosensory signals happens at the low
level of the hierarchy
um that then attenuates the sensory
consequences of this
um of the first year
um
and the math awareness comes uh when you
learn
the when you're I think when you start
having increased body awareness so you
you'll make more experience I think then
you start developing meta awareness
about how your body is actually
um
about higher representation of the body
of your body but in the moment when this
happens uh I think it really happens
that the low levels of personal beliefs
and then later on the longer time scales
then it starts becoming uh more abstract
and ingrained in your personal uh at the
personal level of your beliefs
that's how I stay but of course uh if
Simon has something to do with it um
yeah it's really open
I know I didn't I didn't want to comment
that I just selfishly erased my hand to
ask another question Yeah okay or Daniel
I don't know if you have an opinion on
that I'm happy to hear it as well
well certainly
resonated with uh this comparative
approach to studying the the diversity
of
methods and protocols we already have
for mind and body and attention
broadening the scope and just kind of
pointing putting darts in the space of
of what practices do people engage their
mind and body in and then how can that
territory be explored with also a
variety of theoretical models and how
does that relationship connect to the
kinds of empirical work that we might do
in a brain scanner or um with other
kinds of measuring
um and I think one thing I
I I
want to explore more is like in a
hierarchical nested cognitive model
which we often speak of ourselves and
other uh types of sophisticated entities
as
where's our awareness where's awareness
Matt picture and um
and and also to Simone's question about
um when we're moving
but we're expecting what we're moving
then how does the exteroceptive flow
like the visual field you might be very
familiar with walking and so you might
be able to proprioceptively kind of zero
out on your walking
but there's this extra receptive
um flow of novelty in the world
so I think that that how
um and then connected back to the
comparative and staring at a candle or a
blank screen or darkness and all these
different methods
um
it's it's there's a lot that that
these questions bring up
yeah
thank you Daniel so I I have something
to add to that because I think it's
super important so um
so for me it's not so you know my
background is like in body cognition and
activists and everything and for me it's
really not at all surprising the fact
that many of these techniques have been
developed by people that kind of like
lived in closed communities right so
it's like you have a space where people
can you know meditate walking I don't
know and then they have this ritual they
wake up at this time and they do this
thing so you put yourself in a yeah it's
a ritual right like all the
to reach also so this means it's like as
I said it's like high predictability
right
um and then that's that's something
super super uh important yeah and even
if even in the
walking meditation you need to
um follow a certain path
um uh yeah so that's that's super
interesting
well
um in in the last uh five or ten minutes
I would love to hear from each of you
like what are your directions heading
forward and and what's the um
what's exciting to you and where would
you like to take this
maybe um Simone and Julia first and then
we'll kind of make our way back to the
authorship
I mean I mean I'm not not myself not
working on the project right but like
what I what I was really interested in
sort of extending this is trying to
understand
um because the way
the way those deep meditative states are
reported sometimes and the way
um people with depersonalization
disorder report their experience is very
similar they almost did like the same
words right and to describe how they
feel and I wonder why one is experienced
positively and one is experience so
negatively as in it being a disorder and
completely disrupting someone's life
so that was like this this comparison I
think I would be very uh curious about
awesome Julia if you want to add
anything
um we're not it's it's very interesting
and um yeah I mean again I'm not so
involved in this study so it's a bit
hard but I mean I'm really interested in
the I mean all the Selfies affected by
yeah our interaction with the world
external world so uh and I'm completely
already spoiled with the result we have
with the international binding so um
uh it's very interesting I mean yeah
it's the self is attenuated or um if
it's disappear kind of I think that's
the key uh question we want to ensure
and uh yeah I would be very curious to
know I mean what very I found in uh data
uh to see if we can have a common
narrative about what's happening
um also with the personalization
um yeah it's very interesting to see how
moving or body I mean attention uh to
the body can really change the self kind
of for the way we process sales
information
um yeah so very interesting
or honor
yes so
um there's like lots of work to do ahead
but that's exciting right
um
yeah so very short term it's like we
need to write up this results that we
just got
um so yeah in relation to the body so
basically going to have some numbers to
show so that's that's super nice
um and then the next steps would be to
um you know
um
create or develop a computational model
around this yeah with basically contrast
you know the real world data with you
know um
simulation data and then uh yeah so have
a multi-layer type of like approach with
different methods from physiological to
behavioral to phenomenological to
computational potential also neural so
that's something with would be nice to
do in the next steps yeah
um so yeah
um and apart from that I think that's
all for now uh and I'll let uh I'll
leave uh the flow to Valeria
well again thank you again
and I know everybody uh yeah I I also
wanted to thank you a lot for this
platform this invitation it was yeah
really nice a really nice person and
really nice conversation
um
I'm working with on in these projects so
she already said what what's the the
next Direction on what I can add in this
I think would be
on the theoretical side also start
engaging with
um
more closely to bodily reactions to
meditation because the body boundaries
the solution is just one part of it it's
like one part of the phenomenology but
it's not the only thing that happens
during meditation
um there is a lot of potential that can
be discovered uh on this because
um
because the body boundary is the
solution again it's really study a lot
but it's a phenomenon and there is so
many other things that happens in our
body while we meditate and you I I speak
for first first person experience but in
the community it's really like already
sad other kinds of also um uh more
healing Traditions like breath work for
example
there there is a lot of potential where
people already work on that but there is
no Bridge uh with the academic
communities so people work pragmatically
with this intuitive knowledge as well
what happens in the body during these
alternate States Of Consciousness but
still we need to rage it with uh trying
to make sense from a phonological and
scientific point of view an experimental
point of view as well so I think I see
myself in yeah trying to step in this
tour then like bring Insight from one
world to the other and
opening uh to help myself and the other
people around me yeah
awesome well
it's the Vlog with the work that sounds
really exciting love the idea of the the
two-way street with different bodily and
cognitive practices and
collaboration and conversation that can
bring in all these different expertises
that that maybe don't have an fmri study
already
whatever that's worth
thank you though always um any of you
are welcome back and really appreciate
that you all came out
thank you Daniel
thank you see you soon